gardez la france au fond des yeux
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils en apprennent
à tricoter d'accord là dessus à votre
place je la ramène un peu moins mais si
vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous
manque qu'une seule chose un tout petit
détail le trophée des valises à paris
valable
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cet
inattendu très largement consacré à la
présidentielle aujourd'hui nous allons
parler du vote blanc grâce aux archives
de la télévision vous allez voir comment
il s'inscrit dans l'histoire de la vème
république
et puis avec notre invité patrice
duhamel nous allons vous offrir une
petite visite guidée de l'elysée comment
les présidents français se sont
approprié le palais de la république
après d'abord notre traditionnelle revue
de presse avec ludivine lopez et
géraldine corner lavaud bonjour à toutes
les deux alors ludivine nous sommes au
coeur de la campagne et vous vouliez
absolument nous faire partager un temps
fort de la cinquième oui un moment
historique merde c'était le 5 décembre
1965 premières élections au suffrage
universel direct donc pour la première
fois les français vont élire le
président de la république est bien
évidemment les caméras de télévision
étaient là les élection présidentielle
au suffrage universel auront fait
d'entrée une victime l'abstentionnisme
c'est en masse que les électeurs sont
venus choisir parmi les six candidats
dont monsieur marcel barbu celui qui
leur semblait le plus aptes à la
magistrature suprême
85 % dont monsieur tixier vignancour ont
voté ce qui représente la plus forte
participation jamais enregistrée
peu de monde dans les rues sinon devant
les quotidiens ou l'écoutent et la
vision collective avait été organisée
dans de nombreux foyers d'été les
parties groupe est au tour des
récepteurs des amis attentif à la
géographie politique des départements et
à l'évolution des pourcentages
ces réunions se renouvelleront sans
doute aucun des six candidats n'ayant
obtenu au premier tour la majorité
absolue des suffrages exprimés un second
tour de scrutin sera nécessaire et au
deuxième tour le général de gaulle
l'emportait en face à françois
mitterrand et vous l'avez sûrement
entendu là au début de l'archivé
journaliste dit la grande surprise de
cette élection c'est l'abstention enfin
c'était avant d'avoir les résultats
officiels parce que pour sept premiers
l'élection au suffrage universel direct
l'abstention était bel et bien au rendez
vous 15% au premier et au second tour
c'est 15% d'abstentions en 1965 je vais
vous le dire cinquante sept ans plus
tard ça fait presque rêver à quelques
jours du premier tour de la
présidentielle les sondages les
intentions de vote donnent 30 %
d'abstention c'est un niveau jamais
atteint pour un scrutin présidentiel
géraldine effectivement le risque
d'aller vers un record de l'abstention
pour ce premier tour 30% c'est du jamais
vu et d'après les dernières études ce
sont les 25 34 ans et les électeurs de
gauche qui bouderaient l'isoloir
dimanche alors pourquoi ne vont-ils pas
voter d'après les études récentes les
personnes interrogées mettent en avant
deux explications premièrement l'absence
de nouveautés dans les propositions des
candidats mais aussi l'absence de
suspense sur l'issue du scrutin alors
dans les années 60 il y avait toujours
de l'abstention mais les raisons étaient
tout autres regardez lors du dernier
référendum la france a battu un record
celui de l'abstention
quelques six millions d'électeurs plus
de 26 % du corps électoral se sont
abstenus 26% qui n'ont pas dit mot soit
parce que ce jour-là la campagne
semblait plus attrayante que le bureau
de vote
soit parce que c'est dans tauzin vite
très simple d éventaires il a voulu
donner raison à une image d'épinal
depuis longtemps traditionnelle
soit qu'un incident imprévisible un
accident de la rue pourrait-on dire les
détourner du droit chemin alors la
campagne la pêche ou même un petit flirt
1 pourquoi pas rappelons que le 10 avril
c'est tout de même le premier week-end
des vacances scolaires de la zone b
voilà ça c'est l'actualité de la semaine
que s'est il passé à cette même période
de l'année par le passé pour le savoir
il va falloir regarder les api de
l'inattendu
bonjour
dans le monde entier la même nouvelle à
la une de tous les journaux les états
unis entre tanguay le pacte atlantique
est désormais une réalité les deux
représentants des nations occidentales
apposent leur signature au bas du pacte
ce showman signe pour la france
le pacte atlantique dont tous les
ministres présents ont souligné le
caractère défensif unidose nations dont
le seul but est d'assurer la paix une
paix maintenant plus sûres
t'as qu'à soi
à tours à faire
[Musique]
le maire de paris jean tiberi a
déclenché à minuit gigantesque compteur
lumineux installés sur la tour eiffel
un compteur qui égrènera désormais les
jours restant à courir avant le 1er
janvier de l'an 2000 les participants
reprochent à l'organisation mondiale de
la santé oms de ranger leur sexualité
dans la catégorie des troubles mentaux
il estime également que la loi française
est beaucoup trop répressive à leur
égard puisqu'elle interdit toute
relation homosexuelle rang 18 ans qui
n'est pas le cas pour les hétérosexuels
à memphis le 4 avril à 18 heures le
champion de la non violence s'est
écroulé sur le balcon de son hôtel
atteint d'une balle mortelle durant 48
heures la mort de celui qui prêchait la
paix a provoqué une traînée d'émeutes
raciales la haine ne supprime pas la
haine disait martin luther king seul
l'amour y parviendra
bonsoir bonne soirée
[Musique]
c'est un bulletin qui ne dit pas son nom
il représente pourtant de nombreux
partisans la reconnaissance du vote
blanc est une nouvelle fois au coeur de
cette campagne présidentielle plusieurs
candidats qui soit de gauche de droite
ils sont favorables et ce thème de
campagne n'a absolument rien de nouveau
ludivine c'est vrai c'est un sujet
récurrent en période électorale alors
pour les candidats qui y sont favorables
la reconnaissance du vote blanc
permettrait un de réduire l'abstention
de de mieux prendre en compte les
aspirations des électeurs alors ses
revendications vous l'avez dit nathanel
elles sont anciennes et elle dépasse
même le cadre de la delà de l'élection
présidentielle retour sur ce combat pour
la reconnaissance du vote blanc un
bulletin et blanc lorsque les lecteurs
lis dans l' enveloppe un papier blanc
sans aucun nom ou gandil vote avec une
enveloppe vide
le vote blanc une démarche électorales
récurrentes
pourtant elle n'a aucun poids sur
l'issue du scrutin ces bulletins vierges
ne sont pas comptabilisés dans les
suffrages exprimés et c'est ce que
dénonçait déjà gérard gautier dans les
années 90
actuellement le vote blanc n'est pas
reconnue c'est à dire que quand les gens
votent blanc c'est-à-dire font la
démarche d'aller à l'urne ce qui est
déjà important ça démontre une volonté
civique de participer à la vie du pays
et bien leur vote leur suffrage est
assimilé au vote nul au même titre que
quelqu'un qui mur qui ratures au crayon
ou quoi que ce soit sur son butin ce
n'est pas sain pour une démocratie
pour gérard gautier communicants de
profession blanc s'est exprimé c'est
d'ailleurs le nom de son mouvement créé
en 1989 son but la reconnaissance du
vote blanc peut-être que le fait de voir
le vote blanc reconnu comme étant un
suffrage exprimé va faire prendre
conscience aux hommes politiques qu'ils
n'ont pas à quel ont eux aussi à être
sanctionné quand il le faut et ça leur
fera peut être changer de façon de faire
mais la prise de conscience politique a
du mal à prendre après 1993 une
quarantaine de propositions de loi sont
déposées sur le sujet en vain à voter
alors dans les années 2000 le combat
continue pour les défenseurs du vote
blanc d'autres mouvements voit le jour
jusqu'à cette loi votée en 2013
suffrages exprimés 87 majorité absolue
44 pour 87 la reconnaissance du vote
blanc fait l'unanimité à l'assemblée
nationale les députés l'ont adopté
aujourd'hui c'est lydie le parti de
jean-louis borloo qui a défendu cette
mesure vous aviez deux candidats trois
candidats ça vous convenez pas bien vous
pouviez pas l'exprimer maintenant tout
le monde peut vraiment aller voter et
compris le vote blanc je pense que cette
année une avancée démocratique majeur
dorénavant les bulletins blancs sont
différenciés des bulletins nuls ceux qui
sont raturé ou déchirer pour autant ils
ne sont toujours pas comptabilisés dans
les suffrages exprimés victoire en
demi-teinte donc pour les militants
surtout pour ceux de la première heure
la loi a été voté qui fait entrer en
compte ses parts au niveau de leur
comptabilisation les votes blancs des
votes nuls sans pour autant leur donner
légitimité du suffrage exprimé en 2015
la porte parole des citoyens du vote
blanc allait plus loin pour elle les
raisons de la non reconnaissance de ce
vote était clair si le vote blanc
étaient comptabilisés par mille
suffrages exprimés aujourd'hui très
clairement il pourrait invalider une
élection et c'est pour ça que ça pose
problème il ya eu de nombreuses loin qui
sont passés sur le vote blanc aucune
jusqu'à présent n'a permis que ce vote
blanc puisse avoir ce pouvoir là alors
on va insister à le vote blanc ça n'est
pas l'abstention ludivine le vote blanc
at-il le pouvoir d'invalider une
élection tout à fait un vote blanc
exprime et pourraient modifier donc les
seuils électoraux nécessaire pour
atteindre la majorité absolue alors oui
dans ce cas-là l'élection serait
invalidé il faudrait tout recommencer et
ce scénario les français sont prêts à
l'envisager fin mars un sondage révélait
que pour 66 % d'entre eux le vote blanc
devait être prise en compte tiens un
coup d'oeil chez nos voisins européens
c'est souvent utiles ou est-ce qu'on en
est de la reconnaissance du vote blanc
il existe plusieurs cas de figure en
europe il ya les pays qui comptabilise
le vote blanc mais ne prennent pas en
compte comme la france on a dit l'italie
et la belgique ce vin au total qui ne
comptabilise alors pas du tout et enfin
ces pays où le vote blanc est
comptabilisé est donc pris en compte
c'est le cas en suède mais uniquement
pour les référendum aux pays bas en
espagne et en grèce merci beaucoup
ludivine reparlera du vote blanc
d'ailleurs dans dans une prochaine
émission
[Musique]
l'amérique à sa maison blanche
l'angleterre sont ndengue street et la
france son palais de l'elysée siège de
la présidence de la république c'est
aussi la résidence officielle du chef de
l'état alors à quoi ressemble la vie
dans cet hôtel particulier construit au
début du xviiie siècle patrice duhamel
va nous aider à répondre à cette
question patrice duhamel bonjour vous
êtes l'auteur de l'elysée histoire
secret mystère aux éditions pocket c'est
la nouvelle édition alors dans la
première édition vous disiez je cite
l'elysée n'est plus une bulle mais il
sait se protéger du ressac est-ce que
c'est toujours le cas
la difficulté c'est que c'est on est on
est hors du temps et hors du monde dans
la campagne électorale il ya beaucoup de
candidats qui disent x y z et hors sol
etc etc à l'elysée les présidents
presque par nature et physiquement il se
retrouve hors sol alors l'elysée c'est
un bureau fourmi des conseillers mais
c'est aussi un lieu de vie et c'est sur
ce point de vue que l'on va se
concentrer avec vous géraldine sur les
250 m² de l'ailé droite où cette vie
abbas organise et vous vouliez commencer
je crois avec une petite surprise une
petite pépite exactement c'est une
archive qui eux que l'on vient de nous
confier la à l'ina
ce sont des images tournées avec une
caméra baby pâte est donc une toute
petite caméra en juin 1935 c'est inédit
vous êtes chanceux car c'est la première
fois que ces images de repas de famille
ce film de famille diffuser les collèges
et et voilà c'est ce que j'allais vous
demandez donc le président de la rép
blick à l'époque albert lebrun entouré
de sa famille on le voit lors d'un
déjeuner à l'elysée est-ce qu'on est ce
que vous vous reconnaissez les l'endroit
où ils sont c'est un petit peu difficile
c'est un des salons je pense du
rez-de-chaussée alors il y en a quatre
ou cinq en enfilade c'est un de ces
salons là mais ils ont été un petit peu
modifié
par la suite et au début avant l'arrivée
du général de gaulle en 1959 donc ça
fait et sait on est à presque 90 ans l'a
donc il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont
changé mais à mon avis ça doit être le
salon des ambassadeurs quelque chose
comme ça alors je sais qui donne sur le
qui donne sur le parc de l'yser alors
des comptes strict du temps de parole
auquel est soumis l'inattendu bien sûr
on va pas parler des locataires récent
de l'elysée on va commencer par le
général de gaulle évidemment le premier
président sous la vème république
charles de gaulle s'installe à l'elysée
on le voit sur ces images en 1959
janvier 1959 et vous le dit très
clairement dans votre livre lui et sa
femme vivent à l'elysée s'y plaisent pas
pourquoi parce que ils trouvent que
c'est trop grand que c'est pas très
commode il adore est à colombes et donc
qu'ils y voient un week-end sur deux
quand ils sont là le week-end il
s'ennuie un peu le seul moment où ils
sentent bien c'est quand l'heure le
neveu général de gaulle vient dire la
messe puisqu'il ya une chapelle quand
vous rentrez l'elysée sur la gauche il y
avait il y avait une chapelle à ce
moment là c'est devenu actuellement le
bureau de l'ancien chef d'état major des
armées le général georgelin qui pilote
les travaux de la réfection de notre
dame on a pas d'image de la vie privée
de ces messe dans la chapelle des de
gaulle à l'elysée pour voir des images
de la vie privée et plus
particulièrement des appartements privés
il faut attendre le président suivant
georges pompidou qui ouvre grand ses
portes les portes de l'elysée mais aussi
des appartements privés c'est une
première à la télévision française on
regarde et on en parle juste à nous
avons cherché à faire que cet
appartement ressemble un peu à ce que
nous souhaitons à ce dans quoi nous
avions l'habitude de vivre
après sa fausse nouvelle
je crois que c'est mieux d'avoir mis les
deux types e liabeuf la voie à tokyo le
constat
n'y
est pas
alors on sent un tout petit peu quand
même la mise en scène première question
tout d'abord pourquoi en cours pourquoi
cette soumis à cet exercice de laisser
entrer les caméras de la télévision dans
les appartements privés de l'elysée pour
deux raisons d'abord il voulait rompre
avec le style très strictes parfois peu
raide du général de gaulle donner
l'impression que il jouait sur la carte
déjà sur ma paye maintenant la proximité
avec les français et donc il voulait que
les français le voient ce que ce que
effectivement on n'avait jamais vu avec
général de gaulle mais avec de gaulle
c'était absolument impensable la
deuxième raison c'est qu'ils ont ils
voulaient changer énormément chose ce
qu'ils ont fait à l'elysée très vite et
que là on voit les tableaux modernes
polyakov c'est exactement ce que faisait
ce que j'allais vous dire on entend à
claude pompidou parler d'eux des
peintures de poliakoff ils ont fait
entrer ce couple-là l'art contemporain à
l'elysée on le voit sur ces images c'est
la première fois que les locataires
investissent aussi aussi fortement ces
lieux et y en avant le turbo qui ont
changé les choses là plairont à se
changer des choses un polluant premier
napoléon iii la pompadour fit changer
des choses c'est chalon radical est
hélas ça n'a rien à voir là seront
changées de siècle c'était d'un
modernisme est absolument extraordinaire
comment mais comment ça se passe
justement pour pour changer quand on est
locataire de l'elysée on a le droit
d'aménager comme avec il faut la lissant
bien non il faut l'accord il faut la
corde il faut l'accord des représentants
du patrimoine de
du mobilier de ils font ça avec le
mobilier de france où il peut y avoir
tel ou tel meuble à bureaux etc ils
veulent changer de bureau de haut de
tableau etc mais là en l'occurrence le
couple pompidou a fait venir un certain
nombre de grands designers le grand
architecte d'intérieur et ils auront dit
en gros ceux qu'ils aimaient bien ils
ont dit carte blanche à les y voilà une
enveloppe pas pour refaire la déco de
l'elysée à son goût oui oui une ampleur
il ya un budget officiel contrôlé par la
cour des comptes depuis depuis le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy avant il
y avait un budget mais c'était un peu
plus voilà un peu plus souple
1974 donc un nouveau locataire un valéry
giscard d'estaing décide de mettre son
bureau dans le salon d'angle et non pas
dans le salon doré il sera le seul autre
particularité pour la première fois
l'elysée n'est pas vraiment la demeure
du président gère effectivement
important tout comme georges pompidou il
ouvre grand les portes des appartements
privés de l'elysée aux caméras on le
voit à dîner avec ses quatre enfants on
voit sur ces archives là on le voit
aussi jouer avec ses chiens c'est
complètement fait que ça en fait il ne
vivait pas à l'elysée non mais hélas ils
pouvaient déjeuner ou dîner mais une île
ne le couple giscard n'a pas voulu
vivre à l'elysée parce que les enfants
on les voit d'ailleurs là et s étaient
quatre ados en l'occurrence et donc
franchement pour des ados de se balader
en rentrant du lycée ou de l'école avec
des gardes républicains partout et une
sécurité tout à fait particulière
c'était extraordinairement difficile
vous l'avez bien qu'ils habitent pas
vraiment mais tout de même valéry
giscard d'estaing va entreprendre de
grands travaux de rénovation et écoutez
comment il décrivait ce palais de
l'elysée
papa c'est une très belle maison mais
qui a toujours eu des malheurs
historique elle n'a jamais été en
réalité aménagé de façon suivie pendant
longtemps et ce qu'il donnait son style
un peu composites cela passe dans une
pièce
qui est très belle et qu'elle envoie ou
napoléon impliqués après waterloo alors
qu'elle gardait pense qu'il ya fils
empire puis si vous donnez salon moderne
et en os vous avez des appartements qui
ont été aménagés en réalité sous le
ivème république
vous aimez ac maison malgré son peu de
pratique enfin si vous voulez je
souhaite surtout
iota lucas
elle n'est pas sera-t-il qu'elle n'a pas
beaucoup d'amants réalité et je souhaite
qu'elle en est une à mon avis il faut
que la lame de ses propriétaires ce
qu'on fait là par nature changeront mais
vrai qu'elle soit typique d'une certaine
mauvaise rohff en faire une maison sans
âme c'est la définition d'elysée pour
vge comment est ce que vous expliquez ça
j'explique cela par le fait que les
présidents qui se sont succédé à
l'elysée ils savent qu'ils sont pas
sages et puis c'est grand c'est pas trés
alors attendez on va pas on voit pas les
plaindre parce qu'ils ont voulu y aller
c'est superbe parc est magnifique et
c'est vrai que cette immense palais
c'est vide le soir c'est pas trés c'est
quand même pas très commode et puis
c'est pas très commode du travail et non
plus 1995 la famille chirac arrive à
l'elysée ici vivent et ils adorent ça
s'ils cherchent surtout elle surtout
vers nadège alors elle les adore c'est
ce que vous dites dans votre livre elle
adore celui elle aime vivre à l'elysée
et c'est une maîtresse de maison elle
décide de tout la décoration la cuisine
le parc et ça m'a donné envie de vous
montrer peut-être vous remonterez cette
archive plutôt savoureuse où l échange
où elle donne des hommes plutôt aux
jardiniers de l'elysée
rien de ce qui pousse ou de ce qui ne
pousse pas ne lui échappe maîtresse
femme dans la gestion des massifs elle
ne tourne pas autour du pot surtout
quand il s'agit de rose louis benech
paysagiste en chef n'est pas prêt de
l'oublier peut-être ne s'est pas compris
peut-être séparera pas moi mon idée est
d'avoir dans ce parc beaucoup beaucoup
d'autres
je pense c'est moi que dans ces massifs
et your head est réservé aux yeux mais
appelle à la promotion ils sont assistés
normalement à la haye ce qu'on peut
encore rattraper mais beaucoup de
rosiers là alors ce que parce qu'elle
est rosy en hiver il ya des feuillages
tout maintenant sont devenus plus à
protéger
des roses jusqu'à noël
est-ce qu'elle était comme ça à
bernadette à tout contrôler l'elysée
était vraiment sa maison oui et les
personnels de l'elysée ont beaucoup aimé
cette période parce que les choses
étaient claires alors c'est parfois un
peu rude fallait pas trop discuté
avec elle fait des roses et des rosiers
je crois qu'elle avait fait mettre aussi
des orchidées je crois mais elles sont
et sans occuper vraiment et de temps en
temps la nuit et se promener pour voir
dans le palais pour voir si tout était
en ordre s'il y avait de la poussière
sur les meubles vous avez vraiment elle
a aimé et c'est la seule qui ait
vraiment aidé alors on l'a vu donc tous
les présidents finalement eu des des
styles différents ils ont vécu l'elysée
à leur manière mais tous ont toujours le
même mot géraldine pour qualifier ce
palais est oui et c'est étonnant mais ce
mot c'est la prison ça fait d'ailleurs
partie des mots un qui sont dans votre
abécédaire petit florilège
en sommes habités l'elysée c'est
devenir quelqu'un d'autre malgré tout
c'est devenir quelqu'un d'autre c'est un
peu
entré en religion si je peux dire
c'est très réglée par le protocole n'est
ce pas par conséquent on prend quelque
sorte un habit et on fait les gestes qui
vous sont dictées précisé vous manque
t-il quelque chose actuellement oui la
liberté c'est un lieu qui par sa majesté
par son importance par son caractère
symbolique peut être aussi un
enfermement
alors ils sont pas les seuls en a fait
on en a choisi et 3 mai à comparer à
l'elysée à une prison dans le livre vous
citer jean casimir perier raymond
poincaré ou paul deschanel et encore
d'autres est ce que c'est encore le cas
aujourd'hui ce sentiment d'enfermement
de prison en plein coeur de paris il ya
quelque chose d'assez étonnant quand on
arrive à l'elysée c'est que les gens ne
parlent pas fort il chuchote il murmure
c'est extrêmement feutrée à l'elysée ce
qui fait que les présidents ils ont
envie de sortir voilà parce qu'ils de
gaulle il il le faisait venir son
coiffeur il ya pas grand chose à faire
mais une fois parviennent par une fois
par mois à l'elysée dans les
appartements privés et c'était toujours
le même coiffeur qui venait il lui
disait alors qu'est ce qu'on dit en
qu'est ce qu'on dit en dehors ce qu'ils
voulaient savoir et le coiffeur lui ils
avaient pour instruction veux dire
vraiment général ce qui se passait
vraiment ce que les gens
disait et pensez vraiment et général de
vaud libre était beaucoup plus
d'attention cas ce que lui disait ses
conseillers patrice domaine comment vous
imaginez l'elysée de demain dans les
prochaines années est ce que ça ne
deviendra qu'un espace de travail ou est
ce qu'il y aura toujours un président
qui qui entretiendra la la vie dans ce
palais non je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de
présidents de la vème qui ont voulu
essayer d'aller ailleurs général de
gaulle il voulait aller au château de
vincennes j'ai pour des raisons de
sécurité s'était c'était compliqué
d'autres aussi avait imaginé d'autres
lieux voir mais le déménagement en
coûtera une fortune les français adorent
l'elysée ils y sont attachés même quand
il ya des pièces comme celle là le petit
salon d'argent au rez de chaussée c'est
là où napoléon 1er a indiqué le 22 juin
1815 et il ya une anecdote
extraordinaire si j'ai trente secondes
pour la radio c'est un des mystères ce
que les histoires qu'on n'a pas pu te
dire effectivement voilà
le jour où de gaulle quitte l'elysée
deux jours avant le référendum de 69e'
sait déjà qui va perdre le référendum et
d'eau qu'ils quittent l'élysée pour la
dernière fois il déteste ce petit salon
convient de voir parce que c'est là que
la peau les os abdiqué ses lacs ce félix
faure a fait son fameux malaise dans les
bras de sa maîtresse c'est là que la
pole et ont trois à préparer la fin
louis napoléon bonaparte a préparé son
coup d'état le 2 décembre 1851 de gaulle
déteste cet endroit eh bien ils
demandent en quittant l'elysée pour la
dernière fois ils demandent de passer
par ce qu'ils y passent par ce salon il
demande à son chauffeur de le prendre
devant il y allait jamais et il sortait
toujours de l'elysée par la droite de la
cour et l'aï dit au chauffeur
aujourd'hui vous passez par la gauche
pourquoi parce que c'est par la cta paul
et on avait quitté l'elysée voilà une
des nombreuses anecdotes que vous
retrouverez dans histoire secret mystère
de l'elysée votre livre patrice duhamel
avec jacques santamaria aux éditions
pocket mille mercis pour mercier visites
guidées et historique merci à vous
géraldine d'avoir préparé ce dossier
alors on se quitte avec notre
traditionnel pépites à cette semaine une
pensée pour les 12 candidats qui sont
dans la dernière ligne droite avant
l'élection il a peut-être exténué épuisé
fatigué mais les actualités françaises
de
1964 avait peut-être trouvé la solution
pour les détendre un reportage
surprenant mais d'époque
plusieurs présidents directeurs généraux
pense avoir trouvé le moyen d'éviter
l'infarctus du myocarde
grâce à un procédé d'une simplicité
étonnante et qui ne nécessite qu'un
bagage des plus réduits chaque fin de
semaine réunis dans un club plusieurs
chefs d'entreprises pratique tout
simplement le retour aux sources
étonnant bain de jouvence que ce retour
à la simplicité originel voilà ce stage
de vie préhistorique pour les hommes
survenait je vous laisse imaginer nos
candidats dans ses costumes
préhistorique on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine sur le canal 27 toute la
semaine sur les réseaux sociaux que ce
soit celui là où cette france info
émission préparée avec les
documentalistes viviane barney emilie
galtier merci à elle merci bien sûr à
toute l'équipe et merci à vous de nous
suivre chaque semaine sur france info
[Musique]